good afternoon my name is Petra larks I
work for Novartis and our health care
council we are focusing on personalized
medicines and first of all we have tried
to define what it actually is and it's
not this is tradition medicine so we are
very excited by the prospect that more
and more we will be able to give the
right treatment to the right patient at
the right time is a much better efficacy
than today we're discussing what we need
to do to actually make this girl happen
and so we are looking at our health care
systems need to look like to learn the
fusion of this toward to capture their
only kind of fits the increase
productivity my head what does the
regulatory motifs of like and try my
hardest shape the walls of the people
who work in healthcare materials that
need to have and we have the digital
health not only makes the lab patients
phantom and actually want to have a
major contribution to the financing of
the healthcare systems thank you